A
MADE ON LauraIngraham.com ALL
PROCEEDS GO TO CHARITY AND GOT
FELL THIS NEXT.
>> Greg: OF OUR PRODUCERS WAS
STUCK IN THE ELEVATOR FOR HOURS
EVEN AS WE TAPE THE SHOW.
WHILE THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY FREE GENE WAS TAKEN TO
A LOCAL HOSPITAL WHERE THEY
EXAMINED HIS KNEE WHICH
APPARENTLY STRAINED WHEN THE
ELEVATOR PLUNGED TEMPORARILY,
WERE HAPPY THAT IS WELL THOUGH
AND WISH THEM LUCK IN HIS FUTURE
CAREER ENDEAVORS.
YES, YES, YES WE MISSED WE FIRED
HIM BECAUSE HE MISSED HIS SHOW.
I'M RUNNING A TV SHOW NOT IN.
I JUST WISH THAT WE DO CHANCE
MEET HIM FIRST.
SO SPEAKING OF TRAPS SHOULD WE
TALK ABOUT TAYLOR LAURENTI PUPPY
DON'T KNOW WHERE BUT WHATEVER.
SHE WAS A FORMER DISHONEST
REPORTER "THE NEW YORK TIMES" AS
IF THAT NARROWS THINGS DOWN A
MACHINE MADE HER LIVING CREEPING
AROUND THE WEB TRY TO FIND
PEOPLE TO CANCEL FOR SAYING
INAPPROPRIATE STUFF, A REAL
JERK.
SHE THEN BECAME A DISHONEST
REPORTER FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TO DO THE
SAME THING.
IS THE PART OF BEING A LEFTY,
SCREWING UP ONLY GET TO A BETTER
JOB SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BUT BETWEEN BEING A SLIMY SLUG
SHE WON AN MSNBC TO TALK ABOUT
HOW SHE WAS A VICTIM OF ONLINE
MARBURY.
>> CAN YOU DRAW A PICTURE OF
WHAT IT'S LIKE WHAT SEARCH OF
HARASSMENT HITS?
>> IT'S COMPLETELY OVERWHELMING
AND IT'S NOT JUST ME EITHER.
THE IMMEDIATELY DOCS YOU WILL GO
IF YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS, THEY TRY
TO LOOK UP EVERYONE WHO EVER
ASSOCIATED WITH YOU.
>> IT FEELS LIKE ANY LITTLE TINY
PIECE OF INFORMATION THAT GETS
OUT ON YOU WILL BE USED BY THE
WORST PEOPLE ON THE INTERNET TO
DESTROY YOUR LIFE.
AND IT'S SO ISOLATING.
IT'S HORRIFYING.
IT'S REALLY HARD.
>> Greg: IT REALLY IS THERE'S
NOTHING FUNNY ABOUT IT TIME TO
MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES UNBEARABLE
THROUGH ONLINE MARBURY.
UNLESS IT HAPPENS TO SOMEONE WHO
MAKES A LIVING MAKING PEOPLE'S
LIVES UNBEARABLE THROUGH ONLINE
MARBURY IS FUNNIER THAN WOMEN
TRYING PUT CLOTHES ON AT
LULULEMON.
SHE WAS A BREATHLESS ONLINE COP
BUT WAITS EAVESDROPPED ON AN
ONLINE DISCUSSION FALSELY
ACCUSED A TECH EXECUTIVE OF
USING A SLUR.
AFTER SHE WAS CAUGHT SHE BRAVELY
LOST HER ACCOUNT.
MEANWHILE LIKE AN EVIL
SANTA CLAUS SHE FELT A BLOG THAT
SAID THINGS THAT SHE DEEMED
PROBLEMATIC.
SHE WAS HER OWN CANCER CULTURE
MACHINE, LAGOON, A BULLY AND
WHEN IT SUITED HER A VICTIM.
BUT NOW JUST WEEKS AFTER SHE
CLAIMED TO HAVE SEVERE PTSD,
SEVERE PTSD.
OVERBY AND DOXXED WHICH SHE
CLAIMS IS DUE TO HER GENDER, SHE
IS BACK TO HER OLD TRICKS
CONTACTING FRIENDS AND FAMILY OF
THE WOMAN BEHIND THE POPULAR
LIBS UP TICK TOCK QUIT OR
ACCOUNT.
SHE CLAIMS THAT THE WOMAN'S
POSTWAR ANTI-GAIN IN CITING
OUTRAGE EVEN THOUGH THE USERS
POSTED THE CONTENT THEMSELVES TO
THE ACCOUNT IT SHOWS UNEDITED
ALREADY PUBLIC VIDEOS OF LEFTIES
AND OLDER GREASED HAIR GLORY.
BUT SHE WAS SO OBSESSED SHE WENT
AFTER SOMEONE WITH A SIMILAR
NAME JUST LIKE ME MAKING DRUG
JOKES.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" RAN HER
POTENT.
IN A NAME TO THE LISTING OF HER
PROFESSIONAL LICENSE WITH HER
ADDRESS.
THAT'S DOXXING BY DEFINITION.
THE VICTIM CALLED AND THE TALKER
LAST NIGHT.
LET'S PLAY THAT.
>> HOUSES AFFECTED YOUR LIFE?
>> HAVE TO MAKE SOME TRAVEL
PLANS.
I'M AT A LOCATION ANNOUNCING
ANYONE WILL FIND ME, I'M NOT ANY
OF THE LOCATIONS THAT TAYLOR
LEAKED.
>> Greg: AFTER CLAIMING THAT
SHE WAS TARGETED TAYLOR'S START
ZOOM TARGETING PEOPLE SHE
DEMONIZES HIDE BEHIND THE LIE
THAT SHE'S FIGHTING BIGOTRY.
WHEN A FACT SHE GETS OFF ON IT.
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST" OFFENSE
OR, POSTING PRIVATE EMAILS ARE A
TARGET BUT THEY DID.
SURE THEY EVENTUALLY DELETED THE
LINK, BUT WHAT YOU POST ONLINE
LAST FOREVER JUST LIKE THOSE
CHEESECAKE PHOTOS.
ACTUALLY EATING CHEESECAKE IN
HIM.
[LAUGHS]
NOW IN THE GOOD OLD DAYS BEFORE
SOCIAL MEDIA HER BEHAVIOR WOULD
COST HER A JOB.
WHEN YOU CAN BE A JOB ACTUALLY.
SHE'S DOING THE OPPOSITE
SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER, INSTEAD
USING HER POWER AND POSITION TO
TARGET PLEBES, THAT TAKES A LOT
OF BALLS RIGHT?
ABOUT HER RIGHT UP THERE WITH A
GRADE A PORTERS COVERING THE WAR
ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE.
THEY'VE HEARD THE PHRASE LIVED
BY THE SWORD AND DIE BY THE
SWORD.
WILL I CAME UP WITH IT AFTER
COMING UP WITH MY COLLEGE
ROOMMATE STEVE SORT HE WAS A
WILD MAN.
NEARLY KILLED ME.
BUT WHEN YOU LIVE BY THE MOB YOU
WILL BE CRUSHED BY THE MOB WHO
GOES AROUND EVENTUALLY COMES
AROUND.
SHE LIKED MENTALLY ILL GUY WHO
ATTACKS A WOMAN ON THE STREET.
WHEN THE COPS SHOW UP TO
PHYSICALLY TAKE HIM DOWN HE
SCREAMING POLICE BRUTALITY.
HOW CAN SHE PLAY THE VICTIM,
IMAGINE WORK WITH SOMEONE LIKE
THAT.
>> I CAN'T TAKE THE BULLYING
ANYMORE EVERYONE IS SO MEAN TO
ME AND I JUST CAN'T HANDLE THE
DISRESPECT AND HOW HURTFUL THEY
ARE, OKAY I'M A VICTIM
ALL RIGHT.
I AM THE VICTIM.
>> CAN I GO HOME YET?
>> THREE MORE HOURS, SHUT UP
JERRY.
>> Greg: AS FOR HER SHE'S
WORKED FOR A POWERFUL MEDIA
COMPANIES, SHE'S GOT POWER AND
CLOUT.
SHE CAN RUIN YOU JUST BY
ACCUSING YOU OF SAYING SOMETHING
AND AMPLIFYING IT.
EVEN IF SHE'S A HUNDRED PERCENT
LAUNCH AND NEVER APOLOGIZE JUST
COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
SHE'S A GROWN WOMAN WITH A
MASSIVE MEDIA COMPANY BEHIND HER
OUT IN THE PRIVATE LIVES OF
PEOPLE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY SHE'S MISERABLE
IS NOT ABOUT BEING TARGETED ALL
IT'S ABOUT HOW YOU TARGET
OTHERS.
HER JOY TO HUNT AND THE SCALPING
THAT COMES WITH COUNSEL CULTURE
UNTIL HE CAME FOR HER.
BUT STILL SHE CAN'T STOP, SHE'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF SOMEONE WHO
MAKES A LIVING HAVING OTHERS OF
MAKING A LIVING.
SHE CRIES THE MOB UNLESS SHE IS
LEADING IT.
SO IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
PROTEST IN FRONT OF HER HOUSE
HERE'S THE ADDRESS, NUMBER ONE
HYPOCRITE AVENUE APARTMENT 666.
LET'S WELCOME...
HE'S WRITTEN MORE SCRIPTS THAN
MICHAEL JACKSON'S DOCTOR, TV
WRITER AND PRODUCER ROB LONG.
HIS PREFERRED PRONOUNS ARE DADDY
AND MASTER.
CHIEF OF OUTSPOKEN MIDDLE EAST
AND CONTRIBUTE AN EDITOR OR AT
THE SPECTATOR, CHADWICK MOORE.
SHE'S LIKE A TAXIDERMY BUNNY
SHEET ON THE OUTSIDE BUT
COMPLETELY DEAD ON THE INSIDE.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HE IS SO STRONG HE CAN GO UP
NIAGARA FALLS IN A BARREL MY
MASTER PSYCHES IN THE N.W.A.
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION,
TYRUS.
AS A GUIDE TOWN?
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
SHIA TOWN SHOOTING HOOPS WITH
YOUR BUDDIES AND TELLING JOKES
AND THEN YOU BUILD A SHED FOR
SOME REASON.
WHERE IS TALKING COOL.
WE DON'T JUDGE.
♪ ♪
>> Greg: PART TWO OF GUIDE
TOWN.
[LAUGHS]
>> I MISS PART ONE.
>> Greg: YOU GOT A BACK AND
UNDERSTAND PART ONE.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE
GODFATHER.
NO I GOT FATHER TO YOU WATCH IT
IT'S OKAY ON ITS OWN BUT
GODFATHER ONE AS A GODFATHER
TWO.
>> I GOTCHA, I GOT YOU.
>> Greg: NEEDED TO SO THAT'S
WHAT HER OUT.
IF CANCELING IS YOUR SUPPORT
THEN YOU HAVE TO LIVE BY THE
RULES OF THE GAME RIGHT?
>> IT'S KIND OF WEIRD BECAUSE TO
ME FIRST OF ALL EYES YOU KNOW
ARE VERY HIP WITH THE KIDS SOME
ON THE TICK-TOCK.
I FOLLOW THE TICK-TOCK
APPLICATION PHONE APPLICATION.
THAT'S WHAT YOU CALL IT.
I'VE ACTUALLY ENJOY THIS ONE, I
LOVE THE WOMAN WHO DOES IT SHE'S
SUPER TALENTED.
>> Greg: THE PERSON IS LIBERAL
TICK-TOCK.
>> NOT THAT HARD ALL HER STUFF
IS REALLY REPOSTING STUFF.
VERY LITTLE THAT SHE DOES.
>> Rob: IT'S REALLY STRANGE
THAT THOSE THAT MUCH RAGE.
>> Greg: BECAUSE SHE CHOSE
LIBERAL RAGE TO EXPOSE IT AND
THAT GOT TAYLOR TO GO AFTER.
>> Rob: WITH THE LEFT IS
ALWAYS SAYING IS THAT WE JUST
WERE TO BE HEARD, WE WANT OUR
VOICES HEARD AND THEN WHEN I
HEARD THEY GO WILL [BLEEP].
THE DOXXING AND ALL THE STUFF I
GET IT AND I'VE SAID THE THING
BEFORE BECAUSE I DO SYMPATHIZE
WITH THIS WOMAN NOT THIS WOMAN
BUT THE ONE WHO DOES THE LIBS OF
TICK-TOCK.
WE DID USED TO SEND EVERYBODY A
GIANT BOOK EVERY YEAR THAT HAD
EVERYONE'S ADDRESS AND IT.
I BELIEVE IT WAS CALLED THE
PHONE BACK.
>> Greg: ISIS IN A MOMENT I
DROVE.
>> Rob: TO GET YOUR HAIR CUT.
SOME OF THE STUFF SHE SOMETIMES
EVERYONE'S CRYING ALL THE TIME
AND SAYING THEY BEEN VIOLATED
ALL THE STUFF.
I THINK EVERYONE NEEDS TO SORT
OF TAKE A DEEP BREATH.
I'M NOT TO BE UNSYMPATHETIC FROM
A LITTLE BIT ON SYMPATHETIC.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU MAKE A GREAT
PSYCHIATRIST.
WE TALK ABOUT THAT OUR NEXT
SEQUENCE.
SPEAK TO MIKE >> Greg: THAT'S
THE DREAM.
>> Rob: WHILE ON THE CAST ON.
>> Greg: I FEEL LIKE
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ASSESS THE
MENTAL HEALTH OF TAYLOR WHEN
SOMEBODY GOES AND CLAIMS OF
VICTIMHOOD FOR MAN DOXXED AND
THEN GOES AND DOXIES.
>> I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU IF SHE
WAS IN EVERY LIBERAL I KNOW.
THERE'S ACTUALLY NO DIVERSITY
EVERY SINGLE TIME, THEY SPEND
THEIR LIVES THROUGH THE MOST
HATEFUL THINGS FOR OTHER PEOPLE.
WEAPONIZING THE NUCLEAR ARSENAL
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA THE STOCK
AND HARASS AND DESTROY LIVES.
THE MINUTE THEY GET AN IOTA OF
THAT IN RETURN AS I WILL KILL
MYSELF.
IF YOU KEEP GOING WITH THIS.
I'M THE VICTIM HERE.
IT'S CRY BULLY WHICH IS THIS
TERM WAS INVENTED FOR.
SHE TAKES IT A STEP FURTHER.
>> Chadwick: THIS CREATURE IS
SOMETHING ELSE BUT IT'S ALSO
RIDICULOUS IN THE CUP THAT WE
SAW.
IT'S COMEDY.
>> Greg: IT'S THE SHIELD.
LIKE OH, I WAS SUICIDAL AND THAT
SHE LOCKS HERSELF.
THAT WAY NO CAN COME AFTER ME
AND THEM WHENEVER THING COMES
DOWN SHE'S BACK AT IT.
>> Tyrus: I HAVE HAD SOME BAD
ACTING MY DAY.
SHE'D SOME STUFF.
IF YOU WATCH THAT SCENE BACK.
THERE'S A GREAT SPOT WERE SHE
FORGOT HER LINE.
[LAUGHS]
OR INTERVIEWER TRIED TO HELP
HER.
BECAUSE SHE WAS ALREADY LEANING
FORWARD.
SHE IS BEING DRAMATIC.
SHE SAID IT WAS HORRIBLE.
THEN SHE GOT FRAZZLED BECAUSE
SHE FORGOT HER THING.
THEN SHE DID THE FREIGHT CRY
THAT I NEED A MINUTE.
WHATEVER WAS LEANING FORWARD
BECAUSE SHE HAD SUMMING ELSE
WATCH BACK AGAIN AS A DIRECTOR
OR WATCH IT HOW YOU LIKE TO
WATCH HER MOVIES WERE
SUPERCRITICAL A BAD ACTING.
IT AGAIN.
YOU CAN BE ANY MORE PLANNED OUT
I JUST DIDN'T HAVE ANY MORE TIME
FOR ANY MORE TAKES.
THIS WAS PLANNED.
SHE'S LITERALLY TRYING TO SHOW
HOW HURT SHE IS AND IS COMPLETE
[BLEEP].
>> WHY WAS JUSTIN BIEBER THERE?
>> Tyrus: THERE WERE ALL THERE
TO DO SOMETHING WHICH IS THIS IS
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN PEOPLE GET
TOGETHER AND THEY PLOT LIKE
JESSE'S MALAY WHEN THEY GET
TOGETHER AND SOMEONE'S NOT WITH
THE SCRIPT IS THE SAME THING.
I THINK THE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
ARE THERE FOR SUPPORT HELP HER
WITH A LINE OR SOMETHING ELSE
WAS TO BE CONTRIBUTED BUT SHE
GOT CAUGHT UP IN THE MOMENT I'M
SURE WHEN THEY WERE SITTING AND
TALKING ABOUT IT SHE'S LIKE IT
WAS SO GREAT GOT HER MESSAGE.
>> Greg: IT WAS FUNNY SHE HAS
SEVERE PTSD BUT I THINK IT
REALLY PUTS JOEY JONES IN HIS
PLACE.
>> Tyrus: OR ANYONE WITHIN A
FEW MILES OF UKRAINE.
>> Greg: SHE EXECUTED AGAIN
WITH THE 12:45 P.M. ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF INSANE STUFF THAT'S
HAPPENED OVER THE PAST 24 HOURS.
IT'S BEEN UNBELIEVABLE IT'S
EYE-OPENING TO SEE HOW
SOPHISTICATED AND VICIOUS THESE
COORDINATED ATTACKS HAVE BECOME
I'M GRATEFUL TO WORK AT A
COMPANY THAT TAKES THESE ISSUES
SERIOUSLY SO SHE HAS TALKED
ABOUT HOW SHE IS AFFECTED BY
HUGE COMPANY WILL TALK IN WHAT
THESE CORNET ATTACKS.
SHE HAS MORE POWER THAN ANYBODY.
>> Kat: SHE'S USING
EYE-OPENING WRONG.
[LAUGHS]
WHAT YOU PRESENT TO CARE THAT IS
NOT THE ONE THING THAT YOU DO
WITCHES GO AFTER PEOPLE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS IN THE FIRST
TIME SHE'S DONE THIS.
GOING AFTER PEOPLE AND CANCEL
THEM AND THEN CRY WHEN PEOPLE
GET UPSET ABOUT IT.
IN THE INTERVIEW WAS SO FAKE SO
LET'S SAY IT WAS TRUE.
SHE SAID IN THEIR I HAD NOT BUT
SEVERE PTSD.
JUST I JUST WANT TO DO ANYTHING.
JUST READ IN THE STUFF LIKE OKAY
WHAT MIGHT I RECOMMEND A
DIFFERENT ACTIVITY?
YOU DON'T JUST SIT THERE, I SEE
HORRIBLE THINGS ON THE INTERNET,
BUT THAT'S ONLY WHEN I'M LOOKING
THIS PEOPLE TOLD ME TO KILL
MYSELF THAT I DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT.
>> Greg: I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT
EVERY TIME.
IT'S A COMBINATION OF
MEDICATIONS AND ALCOHOL.
>> Tyrus: I DISAGREE WITH YOU
THAT TWEET WAS A THREAT.
I'M SO THANKFUL THAT I HAVE A
COMPANY BACK IN ME.
BECAUSE IF YOU'VE A COMPANY BACK
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO BRING IT
UP.
>> Greg: THAT SUCH A GOOD
POINT.
WE ARE SO PERCEPTIVE.
>> Tyrus: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: I WISH I THOUGHT OF
THAT.
HE'S AFTER MY JOB.
>> HE IS AFTER YOUR JOB BUT YOU
ARE SPREAD PRETTY THIN LET'S BE
HONEST.
>>